on voit bien le dire vite c'est une race
passé je savais que j'aurais pas dû fuir
largo booster et voyons si la ville pour
nous at-il et le reste du chemin à
question peut tenter coup
tu me réponds oui à la vitesse actuelle
à capitaux ont peu ou pas j'en ferais
tout au hockey pour la séparation des
boosters terminée
[Musique]
[ __ ] si ça marche pas on est mort
le réservoir principal est là zéro
consomme pas raté la cage du rêve
d'avoir dit
brian on va trop lentement
on va pas y arriver
[Musique]
si vous me regardez alors vous savez
maintenant qu'un gros problème se dirige
vers nous une réunion d'urgence est
prévue à l'endroit habituel au plus vite
de pékin ce faire
j'ai fait une découverte effrayante
j'ai besoin de vous pour contacter la
nasa immédiatement un bug de nasa on
peut dire qu'on est un petit peu en
froid alors ça va changer
quand vous leur direz que la lune est
sorti de son orbite
aucune raison de paniquer je suis
partout
cherche-t-il à cacher tout ça il est
trop tard pour l'arrêter
vous aviez tout compris avant la
naissance c'est vous la source anonyme
oui
nous avons affaire à une entité
intelligente
année une mission pour attaquer cette
chance c'est de ton aide dont j'ai
besoin
je veux qu'il soit correct
si la lune est vraiment ce que tu penses
tu viens avec nous
d'étoilés
il a bien dit on de gravité
[Musique]
c'est fou
mon but
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi le plan la lune sauver la
terre
c'est pas moi
attention
tu vas voir fiston
[Musique]
il est en mode avion